hi guys this is luca from
lucanomprada.com and today i wanted to
talk
about how to deal with criticism when
you speak a foreign language now if you
ever decide to make a youtube video or
a couple of youtube videos or a youtube
channel brace yourselves guys because
you're in for a treat you're going to
get a lot of praise you're going to get
a lot of admiration you're going to get
a lot
of positive comments but you're also
going to get a lot
of flack for making youtube videos or
for becoming a public figure for getting
yourself out there and this
is perfectly normal now what i'm going
to talk about
is the general criticism that you get
when you speak a foreign language
because let's face it when it comes to
speaking a foreign language
you have to expose yourself you have to
get up there and make it happen
and inevitably you're going to get some
flack or some negative comments i'm
going to touch upon
three main points here that i think are
important and
three kinds of ways to deal with
criticism
the very first thing and the very first
point i wanted to touch upon is the fact
that when you whenever you get some sort
of criticism
do not focus too much on the content of
the criticism
itself or the nasty comments or the
nasty criticism
in general but focus on the why the
person
gave you that critical comment
and i recently stumbled upon a very
interesting video that lindy bodis made
with another female polyglot
lindy botis by the way is she's a
fantastic polyglot and i'll
put a link in the description box you
should definitely check her out if you
don't know her
and what struck me is that
this girl told lindy lindy you're
wonderful and i really like what you do
now but the very first time that i
watched your videos
i hated you and i hated you because you
were so good
and you were better than me something
along those lines and that
struck me because first it was very
honest and second
it is the elephant so-called elephant in
the room
this kind of envy that we all feel
towards other people other people's
abilities
especially within the language learning
world and nobody talks about you can see
it indirectly
in the negativity and the nastiness of
youtube comments but the reality is
that this is present this is part of the
human nature
and this is when when i when i watched
that when i saw
this girl telling lenny butt is what she
honestly thought that struck a chord
with me because
let's face it everybody myself included
have felt some sort of envy when you
observe someone else's skills language
skills and you've been struggling with
your target language and that person
speaks it
effortlessly you want to strangle them
or i don't know it doesn't necessarily
have to be about language learning it's
you're working it's august it's
scorching and
then you see you scroll your facebook
or instagram feed and then you see your
friend with a beautiful girl on a beach
at some tropical island and then you
fell you feel envy
uh for them that's totally normal so the
very first point is
whenever you get a negative comment
focus on the reason why they'll have to
come and most of the time
it's about them it's not about you so
don't take it personally
these people are driven by negative
emotions
and you understand that by looking at
yourself
and saying okay i feel that or i have
felt
to that too second gen hate generates
hate that is negativity generates
negativity you might have observed that
i'm pretty sure if if you are on youtube
often that
in the comment section when someone
leaves a nasty comment
you have a deluge of answers it's always
back and forth you suck no you suck and
people start
insulting each other and up to a certain
point it's en entertaining but then you
realize that
you've spent a lot of time looking at
this back and forth and you wasted
30 40 50 or even 60 minutes of your life
sometimes even more
and then you tell yourself okay you
should tell yourself i should have done
something more productive and
if you do that on a single day every
single day then
that accumulates and imagine the amount
of time that you spend doing this
instead of doing something more
productive so my piece of advice is that
whenever
you get a negative comment i know i know
that it's difficult or you get a
criticism not just a comment on youtube
videos but also in real life
don't dwell too much on it and because
then if you think about it you're you're
trying to reply
oh um i should have told this person
this when they told me directly or i
should have reacted this way
or if they left a comment on
your comment on your video on youtube
but then you want to reply
it's a waste of time block it there you
have to break the chain
before you get sucked into the rabbit
hole you cannot control what people
think
or say about you but you can't control
what you think
about yourself what you feel and
take over your life take control of your
life because
let's face it guys life is short and we
don't have much time on this planet
the third point i wanted to make is that
it all depends on how you react
and whenever you got a negative comment
transform it into positive energy and
transform it into one
concrete action to be the better version
of yourself
let me give an example recently i made a
a video in greek speaking greek and i
got a lot of praise and people were
happy but i
you know needless to say i got also some
flack or some
negative comments some were very helpful
and i got a lot of
helpful comments for example by one
person in particular
who detailed all my uh pronunciation
mistakes or
my phonetic patterns that i was not
getting right
and i'm very grateful for that but there
was another person who
left somewhat a nasty comment i know
because i know this person
i've i've seen this person and i know
why they left this comment
so i understood the why but that person
said that
again my some some words i pronounced
wrong i pronounced some words in the
wrong way the wrong patterns i had
absorbed the wrong
pattern some wrong patterns in greek and
i said well he's right he's actually got
a point
so what i did is instead of dwelling on
oh this guy left a nasty comment and
this and that
i could not care less i focused on the
positive aspect of
receiving such a comment and focusing on
how can i make these
patterns right and it's not about how to
prove
this person right how to prove this
person wrong
it's about how to prove myself right so
whenever you leave
you you get a comment that is somewhat
negative transform it into a positive
action that's what i did i took for
example i started
contacting this other person who left me
a detailed analysis of my
phonetic patterns in greek and we
started working together and also
started working together working on my
pronunciation trying to get it
right in this regard two quotes come to
mind one
is from eleanor roosevelt who i greatly
admire is that
nobody can make you feel inferior
without your consent and the second one
is 10 is what happens to your life 90
is how you react to it so think about it
and every time that you receive a
negative comment be it on youtube or
someone reply to you on the comment
section or in real life
a tutor a friend a complete stranger
criticized your language patterns for
whatever reason focus
on why did it happen did not happen and
try to find a solution like invest your
time
not on the negative uh you know aspect
of it but on the positive acts of it
what can i learn from that so thank you
for
uh watching if you also like this
vlog-like style i'll make more of them
in the future possibly on a weekly basis
let me know how you deal with criticism
in
the comment section below and again
stay away from negativity in this
comment session
and in general in your life as always
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
the next video
you